[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend pandemie politik wird gerade von
angst getrieben angst davor dass die
mutationen des corona virus die solche
schneller beschleunigen könnten als
impfungen sie aufhalten werden deshalb
kehrt zurück was es nicht noch einmal
geben sollte einreisesperren seit heute
sind für menschen die nicht deutsche
sind oder fest in deutschland bohnen
einreisen aus brasilien südafrika und
näher an zu hause auch aus portugal
großbritannien und irland verboten
weitere mutanten hotspots werden sicher
folgen
grenzen sind von haus aus 2schneidig an
der deutsch französischen grenze ist es
frankreich dass beschränkungen und
kontrollen wieder einführt nicht alle
maßnahmen leuchtenden betroffenen ein
vieles ist noch im fluss
susanne freitag berichtet aus dem
grenzgebiet des salats in ihrer bäckerei
in petit rosell ist die kundschaft seit
jahrzehnten zur hälfte französisch und
zur hälfte deutsch
heute ist das lokalfernsehen in rosmarie
hooks bäckerei und der abgeordnete der
nationalversammlung christoph waren alle
sorgen sich wieder mal um die situation
an der grenze
denn wenn alles so kommt wie der
französische premierminister ist gestern
angekündigt hat dann müssen ihre kunden
aus deutschland ab montag einen
negativen pcr test bei sich tragen das
versteht doch kein mensch mal machen sie
die grenze auf dann wieder zu ich weiß
nicht was ich denken soll so ein test
kostet 150 euro das geben die leute doch
nicht aus um ein baguette zu kaufen und
diese situation finden sie an 39
grenzübergängen zwischen lothringen und
dem saarland
nur ein paar meter weiter zeigt
christoph arendt uns wo das problem
er geht einmal von frankreich nach
deutschland und wieder zurück von
deutschland nach frankreich wie tausende
menschen dass sie jeden tag tun
sie haben sicherheitshalber schnell noch
mal eingekauft
ich weiß nicht was hier gerade läuft
ich hoffe vor allem dass das hier alles
bald vorbei ist die angst vor
grenzschließungen ist irgendwie immer da
die kopie krise hat offengelegt wo es
hakt zwischen deutschland und frankreich
auch beim arbeitssystem filippo jung ist
grenzgänger
er lebt in frankreich arbeitet im
saarländischen völklingen als ausbilder
beim tüv letzten märz hatte er
kurzarbeit wegen corona und plötzlich
500 euro weniger lohn auf dem konto das
steuerrecht in deutschland hat eine
lücke bei den deutschen wird die steuer
direkt vom gehalt abgezogen und das
haben sie bei uns dann auch gemacht das
dürfte eigentlich nicht sein wir
versteuern das kurzarbeitergeld doch
auch noch in frankreich deutschland hat
grenzschließungen für den fall
angekündigt dass die mutationen sich in
nachbarländern zu stark ausbreiten
das ist in lothringen derzeit nicht der
fall dennoch stehen an dieser deutschen
tankstelle französische kunden schlange
man weiß ja nie wir machen uns sorgen
wir sind total daran gewöhnt einfach
nach deutschland zu fahren
deutschland und frankreich sind hier
total miteinander verwoben wenn auf der
einen seite virus mutations gebiet ist
es ist auf der anderen seite auch wir
sind ein gemeinsamer lebensraum und so
müssen wir auch verhandelt werden in
paris wird offenbar gerade über eine
sonderlösung beraten
hier wo europa täglich gelebt wird zeigt
sich am deutlichsten wo seine grenzen
sind und weitere corona informationen
jetzt kompakt gepasst
das robert-koch-institut verzeichnet
weiter eine hohe anzahl an übertragungen
obwohl sie in der tendenz sinkt 12.300
21 neuinfektionen meldet dass er binnen
24 stunden das sind 4096 weniger als
noch vor einer woche
794 menschen sind in verbindung mit coop
19 gestorben die sieben tage incidents
für deutschland liegt heute bei 91 die
em verordnung für deutschland soll
überarbeitet werden das hat
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen heute
angekündigt man werde weiter im prinzip
der priorisierung festhalten demnach
werden menschen ab 80 jahren und das
personal in pflegeheimen zuerst geimpft
die im verordnung müsse aber in
deutschland an die altersempfehlung für
den neuen dritten impfstoff von
astrazeneca angepasst werden mit
zunehmender dauer der chor ohne
einschränkungen verschlechtere sich die
situation von kindern und familien so
waren die kassenärztliche
bundesvereinigung in der ärzte und
therapeuten würden von einer massiven
zunahme verhaltensauffälliger kinder
berichten die situation in den familien
hat auch bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
aufgegriffen als einen gewaltigen
kraftakt für familien beschreibt sie in
ihrem wöchentlichen podcast die
gegenwärtige situation und wirbt um
geduld
diese pandemie ist die erste große
internationale krise die großbritannien
und die eu ohne einander getrennt und
sogar vielfach zerstritten überstehen
müssen
boris johnson der ja zuerst eine trump
artige verhandlungs verharmlosung
kampagne gegen die wand gefahren hatte
setzt inzwischen darauf dass eine
erfolgreiche impfkampagne die sünden des
anfangs vergessen macht jedenfalls
verhindert corona gerade das an diesem
wochenende genau ein jahr nachdem briggs
ist ein scharfes licht auf die praxis
bilanz geworfen wird die es aus sicht
der betroffenen briten alles andere als
eine ungetrübte freude berichtet andreas
stamm von den inseln ihrer majestät
alles lief rund satte zuwächse im
geschäft mit dem kontinent dass käse aus
nordengland gar französische gaumen
erfreut dass halten sie bei der jazz
company bis heute für ein kleines wunder
die käserei macht bislang ein fünftel
des umsatzes mit einzelbestellungen aus
europa rund 300.000 euro jährlich aus
und vorbei über nacht als erneuerer der
brh exit real wurde die übergangsphase
endete obwohl sie dachten sie wären auf
die folgen des last minute handels
vertrags vorbereitet und zwar klar dass
jede palette für den großhandel von
einem veterinär zertifiziert werden muss
für 180 pfund aber nun stellen wir fest
dass wir das sogar bei jedem einzelnen
direkt besteller brauchen der über
unsere webseite für 25 oder 30 euro was
kauft eigene milchproduktion
traditionell und flexibel gerade noch
erfolgsmodell jetzt auslaufmodell
denn für klein- und mittelständler lohnt
der handel mit dem kontinent kaum noch
ihnen wird sogar von regierungsstellen
geraten eine dependance in der eu zu
eröffnen um im geschäft zu bleiben das
überlegt auch die käserei zwölf neue
arbeitsplätze würden dann nicht in
macclesfield sondern in frankreich
entstehen
dieser streit um die impfstoffe zeigt ja
wie die spannungen zunehmen eine angst
ist dass sich nun in europa investieren
und dann kommt es zu einem handelskrieg
und alles wäre verloren
ein handelskrieg
im streit der eu mit dem hersteller
astrazeneca um impfstofflieferungen
hatte brüssel gestern fast eine
sonderklausel des brh exit vertrags
aktiviert die im prinzip grenzkontrollen
zwischen nordirland teil des vereinigten
königreichs und eu mitglied irland
erlaubt hätte diese grenze offen zu
halten ein wiederaufflammen des
bürgerkriegs zu verhindern
vier jahre cebr exit verhandlungen hatte
es gebraucht hektische telefon
diplomatie zwischen london und brüssel
verhinderte gestern schlimmeres die
regeln für nordirland sollen den frieden
bewahren und den handel zumindest was
den handel angeht funktioniert das nicht
es verursacht verwerfungen und ich bin
besorgt über die spannungen in der
bevölkerung denn der sonderstatus
nordirlands das weiter teil des eu
binnenmarkts geblieben ist nach große
probleme statt obst und gemüse leere
supermarktregale die frischwaren die wie
bisher aus dem rest des vereinigten
königreichs kommen verrotten an der
neuen zollgrenze obwohl nicht mal alle
neuen regeln angewendet werden sind
lieferanten spediteure kontrolleure
überfordert gerade steckt wieder eine
lieferung von zwiebeln fest der grund es
fehlt an einem zollbeamten der sich die
ware anschaut bestätigen kann
das sind zwiebel langfristig so ökonomen
könnte der eu austritt der britischen
wirtschaft mehr schaden als die korona
pandemie
doch die überdeckt momentan die brics it
folgen noch
nachrichten nun von gundula gause
russland bereitet sich auf die für
morgen erwarteten neuen proteste vor
in über 100 städten wollen
oppositionelle auf die straßen gehen für
die freilassung von kreml kritiker
navalny und gegen die regierung von
präsident putin die behörden warnen vor
einer teilnahme an dem nicht genehmigten
protesten
unterdessen hat ein russischer
milliardär und enger vertrauter von
putin erklärt er sei eigentümer des
palastes am schwarzen meer
navalny hatte in einem video behauptet
das anwesen gehöre putin was dieser
bestreitet
bei einem selbstmordattentat auf einen
militärstützpunkt im osten afghanistans
sind mindestens 15 soldaten getötet
worden
zu dem anschlag bekannten sich die
radikalislamischen taliban
trotz der laufenden friedensgespräche
zwischen den taliban und der
afghanischen regierung gibt es immer
wieder anschläge auf sicherheitskräfte
in zahlreichen französischen städten
sind insgesamt fast 33.000 menschen
gegen das geplante sicherheits gesetz
auf die straßen gegangen
allein in paris beteiligten sich über
5000 demonstranten
dabei kam es auch zu ausschreitungen die
polizei setzte wasserwerfer ein
die demonstranten fürchten durch das
gesetz beschränkungen der pressefreiheit
weil die verbreitung von aufnahmen von
polizeieinsätzen eingegrenzt werden soll
die proteste richten sich zugleich gegen
die korona maßnahmen die zur schließung
von museen kinos und theatern geführt
haben von allen kulturstätten die
derzeit pandemie bedingt brachliegen ist
die hamburger elbphilharmonie eine der
prächtigsten und modernsten und ziemlich
sicher die teuerste und auch dort
versucht man aus der zwangspause das
bisschen gute rauszuholen was
rauszuholen ist im fall der alfie wird
was nachgeholt überfällige
säuberungsarbeiten gewaltig groß und
doch ganz fein sven ricken berichtet aus
hamburg
nur das wirklich gute ohr kann wohl
hören dass die orgel der elbphilharmonie
leicht verstimmt ist auch bernd reinartz
hätte nicht gedacht dass er schon nach
vier jahren die pfeifen seines
meisterwerks bietet
der orgelbauer nimmt sie alle schießt
sie sind empfindlich mindestens einmal
in die hand
zweifel haben bärte wir haben lippen
eine unterlippe eine oberlippe einen
seiten und einen förderbar
also ist alles sehr menschlich was wir
hier tun
schuld an der reinigung nach so kurzer
zeit ist das späte bauende der
elbphilharmonie alles wurde auf den
letzten drücker fertig für eine
endreinigung blieb keine zeit die ganz
kleinen pfeifen da gib mal ganz
vorsichtig mit einem pinsel durch oder
auch wirklich sowieso ein pfeifen putzer
sowas dadurch und bei größeren pfeifen
in diesen riesigen holzpfeifen die er
bis zu elf meter lang sind da wird auch
richtig einfach mechanisch ausgesaugt
4765 pfeifen und keine ist wie die
andere
immerhin haben die orgelbauer aus bonn
zeit das konzerthaus liegt brach
sinnbild für die kultur die hier sonst
stattfindet die elbphilharmonie versucht
gegenzuhalten im netz aktuell mit dem
rising stars festival also den kommenden
stars der klassikwelt dass aris quartett
wäre in diesem jahr richtig
durchgestartet wäre
es ist sehr sehr viel ausgefallen vieles
wurde verschoben
viele sachen auf die wir uns sehr
gefreut hatten für die man so viel
arbeitet die konten nicht stattfinden
konzerte in großen konzerthäusern
usa-tournee solche sachen das ist
natürlich sehr schade ist
[Musik]
eine verlorene musiker generation die
zurzeit nur virtuell gehör findet danach
wuchs der ist sicher ausgebremst da gibt
es einfach viele die hoffnungen hatten
die jetzt vom musizieren leben wollten
die gerade fertig mit dem studium und da
kommt buchstäblich nichts rein dem
müssen zum teil um denkt man sich andere
betätigung suchen und die
elbphilharmonie platt trotzdem monat für
monat weiter irgendwann wird das
musikalische leben zurückgeben
auch bernd reinartz gibt sein bestes
damit wenn es wieder losgeht die orgel
gut klingt die meiste arbeit ist dann
wenn ein ton besonders gut gelungen ist
dann müssen die anderen auch so machen
irgendwann so viel steht fest werden
diese klänge auch wieder vor publikum
erklingen die orgel der elbphilharmonie
jedenfalls ist dann bereit so sauber wie
nie
eine nachricht ist heute auch das wetter
in deutschland so zwei gespalten es war
trübe und nass im süden sonnig und
winterlich im norden der schnee im alten
land bei hamburg machte zwar vielen
freude eis und glätte führten aber auch
zu zahlreichen unfällen
auch der fernverkehr der bahn war auf
vielen strecken beeinträchtigt im süden
dagegen tauwetter regen und hochwasser
auf dem rhein bei karlsruhe musste die
schifffahrt eingestellt werden
und der deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor
weiter anhaltendem tauwetter in
baden-württemberg und bayern
außerdem regnet es morgen ganz im süden
auf den bergen fällt schnee sonst sonne
an den küsten schneeschauer bei minus
zwei bis plus 4 in baden-württemberg 7
grad
die neue woche beginnt mit regen und
schnee nur im norden mit sonne der
temperatur kontrast verstärkt sich
wieder am mittwoch nur ein grad an der
ostsee aber 15 grad am oberrhein
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 36 33
36 40 43 superzahl 1 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und dem
zdftext morgen haben sonntag sind wir
zur normalen journal zeit wieder da
21.45 verabredet mit
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen wegen der klippen im strom der
impfstoffe und mit einem gespräch mit
barack obama über zeitenwenden in den
usa bis dann
und jetzt empfehlen wir ihnen der
sportstudio guten amt bestanden
[Musik]